think back to your childhood for a
moment when you used to play hide and
seek where was your go-to hiding spot
the one place you knew for sure that no
one would ever be able to find you
outdoors it might have been inside a
garden shed or garage or maybe you had a
tree house where you could lay low as
the seeker searched hopelessly for you
indoors on the other hand normally no
hiding place can beat a wardrobe closet
or cabinet when it comes to keeping
yourself totally undetected but what if
there was a cabinet you could find
yourself getting lost in something that
looks small from the outside but that
contains an unknowable amount of
interior space within we call it
scp-432 although some of the researchers
have given it the rather adequate
nickname of the cabinet maze and it is
why you are here why we at the scp
foundation have gathered you because
you'll be our next expedition inside
scp-432
now before you start to argue we're not
going to send you in there empty-handed
you'll be provided with the standard
equipment for a mission like this make
sure you've got your handheld flashlight
with you and enough additional batteries
your headsets have a microphone that
will relay audio back to us at control
and we'll be watching everything through
the camera units you will have mounted
to your shoulders you should also take
two bottles of water each and the same
in energy bars we said only two don't
try to sneak extra we'll know finally
you all need eight sticks of these chalk
markers they're luminous you're going to
be leaving indicators once inside
scp-432
and that will help you navigate your way
around well they should help hopefully
as some of you may have heard this will
not be our first expedition into scp-432
and likely won't be our last either
although it's highly irregular given the
complications encountered on our
previous missions we'll be providing you
with some select details relating to a
few of these aforementioned prior
investigations if you were all paying
attention when you were first briefed
about this then you'll already be aware
that scp-432 is a steel storage cabinet
first discovered in an abandoned
industrial complex in the united kingdom
of course if that's all it was then we
wouldn't be sending you into it the
first expedition into scp-432 didn't
involve a group anywhere near this size
that time we just sent one d-class into
the cabinet once he stepped inside his
camera feed showed us our first recorded
look at the interior from what we could
see the d-class was standing in a
corridor that had been constructed out
of the same corroded rusty metal as the
outer cabinet following our instructions
given via his headset this d-class
subject actually let's call him max
continued down this corridor turning
around a corner a few meters from where
he'd entered max saw a further longer
tunnel ahead although the poor level of
lighting made it impossible to judge
just how far it stretched there was an
ordinary electric light bulb
illuminating part of this corridor but
not enough to make more than a few short
meters visible by the light of his torch
max followed this tunnel over 40 meters
until it split off in varying directions
almost like a crossroads of corroded
metal after conferring with control max
made a mark on the wall nearby pointing
back the way he came towards the exit
that's an important tip for all of you
to remember use the equipment we've
issued you with in order to find your
way back to safety well try to at least
even if it doesn't work making his way
down the left tunnel it was at this
point that max's video feed began to
degrade in quality from the safety of
the control room foundation technicians
noted static lines of interference
shooting across their monitors after
traversing another 11 meters max arrived
at a t-junction in the tunnels and again
opted to follow the left path and marked
the way back with his chalk it was after
that turn that max heard
something the sound didn't make its way
back to control due to all the
distortion and interference when they
asked him what he had heard max waited
the moment listening out for the sound
until there was again as quietly as he
could while still remaining audible he
described the noise somewhere off in the
distance further down the rust-coated
corridor someone or something was
banging against the metal walls there
were even traces of a voice shouting
fearfully into the dark labyrinth
turning up the audio gain on max's
camera the foundation personnel at
control could hear it too noticeably
shaken the d-class continued down the
corridor in the direction of the banging
and shouting only for him to freeze as
he heard a new sound someone screaming
the other noises had stopped immediately
after max was getting more and more
agitated demanding to be allowed to
leave but control urged him to explore
further arriving at another t-junction
he instead went right this time once
more using his chalk to leave a marker
this is your gentle reminder that you
all need to make this a habit when you
go inside
scp-432 the right side tunnel of this
junction led to a dead end and doubling
back to try the left-hand one only ended
up yielding the same result by this
point it had only been 37 minutes since
max had first entered
scp-432 and the foundation doctor
assigned to the cabinet decided this was
enough for expedition 1. max was
recalled ordered to return to the
entrance and he began doubling back the
way he'd come he stopped at the
crossroads remarking that he'd heard
another noise and control had picked up
on the same thing this time it was the
sound of the wind a gentle breeze was
blowing through the tunnel from
somewhere deeper within the maze max's
camera captured a few dead leaves
drifting through one of the tunnels he
hadn't yet explored he was commanded to
collect the leaves for analysis much to
his disapproval by this point he clearly
wanted out as max followed the order and
drew nearer to the uncharted corridor
the deafening sound of a roar echoed
through the tunnel sounding like that of
a bear or a lion in a panic max dashed
back the way he'd come directed by the
chalk markings he'd left on the walls
foundation control demanded that he go
back and investigate the source of the
roaring but he was beyond the point of
listening now desperate to get away from
the dark tangled mass of dimly lit metal
tunnels screaming as he ran max sprinted
through the scp-432 cabinet collapsing
from the sheer overwhelming rush of
terror now much like the first
expedition number two only utilized a
single member of d-class to explore more
of scp-432
obviously there's only so much ground
one person can cover which is why we've
recruited so many of you for the next
excursion don't worry we've already run
the numbers and calculated just how many
of you will make it back in one piece
from the moment the subject of this
second outing who we'll call carrie was
sent into scp-432
her camera feed showed something
particularly
striking the interior of the cabinet
maze seemed to differ from how it began
during expedition one it was as if the
extra-dimensional space within the metal
storage cupboard had somehow changed
itself reconfiguring into a different
layout instructed by control kerry
walked slowly down a long straight
corridor which continued forward for
about a hundred meters before splitting
into a two-way t-junction taking the
right-hand route and leaving behind a
marker she proceeded a further 50 meters
this time around the tunnels within
scp-432 were illuminated more frequently
by light bulbs but not quite enough
carrie still needed her torch to see a
little further into the darkness she
reached to crossroads although it lacked
any chalk markings meaning it was not
the same as the ones first encountered
by max control commanded cary to take
the left side tunnel after leaving her
own marker and she then followed this
new route until hitting a second
crossroads however acting without orders
from the foundation kerry took the right
side passageway despite admonishment
from control she was allowed to continue
however we would advise following any
and all instructions put to you for the
duration of time that you are inside
scp-432
later on ahead of her carries torchlight
showed there to be a third crossroads
but something caused her to stop before
she got closer she reported the noise of
a rhythmic banging that reverberated
through the rusted metal walls of the
labyrinth staying perfectly still trying
to keep her breathing low and quiet
kerry nervously asked about what
scp-432 really was and where that
ominous sound was coming from naturally
foundation control did not provide any
answers as carrie delved further into
the labyrinth her camera feed showed a
number of the light bulbs in this
corridor had been shattered leaving
shards of glass on the metal floor
additionally she noted that there was an
unpleasant stomach churning odor in the
air that smelled like something dead
carrie noticed an object a few meters
later although her camera feed was
beginning to cut in and out as she knelt
down to examine what it was she reported
it was a sports sneaker but as her
camera refocused on the abandoned
footwear the feed suddenly shifted the
angles tilting down towards the floor
that was covered in blood carrie hadn't
realized what it was at first there was
a layer of a dry brown substance on the
corridor floor flaking off in places
looking up under the light of her torch
carrie noticed even more had been over
the walls although it must have been
some time ago given how the blood had
long started to dry out and crack but
that did little to make her feel
comfortable at the site of a long smear
trailing away up the corridor despite
her continued complaints about the
sickening decaying smell control
instructed kerry to collect the shoe and
samples of the dried blood for testing
she asked to be let out of scp-432 but
foundation personnel denied her request
telling her to continue further down the
corridor which she did at a much slower
more reluctant pace it was only when her
video and audio feed started to suffer
heavy interference that control told her
to return by now carrie was panicking
saying she could hear footsteps behind
one of the walls and made her way back
out at a far quicker speed for security
reasons details pertaining to the
foundation's third scp-432 expedition
cannot be shared with you all don't
worry we can still provide you with
information about the fourth and fifth
attempts before you end up heading into
the cabinet maze yourselves in a
departure from the initial two the
fourth of our expeditions featured a
team of three personnel two from d-class
who will be referred to as leo and jade
and one as cp foundation technical
assistant k we aren't currently planning
on sending any more of our own ranks
into scp-432
so when you venture in you'll only have
each other for company plus whatever
else is inside the labyrinth some of the
standard exploration equipment was
divided up amongst the group with only
leo given the luminous chalk markers as
well as a pry bar jade was the only
member given a shoulder-mounted video
unit and for their own safety kay was
issued with a firearm the primary
objective of this exploration of scp-432
was to use an oxidilene cutting torch
operated by k to cut through the
corroded metal walls of the corridors
within venturing inside team made their
way along a series of turns that
foundation control chose at random they
arrived at a crossroads immediately
noticing something that hadn't been
present during the earlier expeditions
the north most passageway of the
crossroads had two large steel pipes
attached to the walls almost like those
found in factories or other industrial
settings upon receiving a message from
control to examine the pipes k remarked
that the metalwork was cold to the touch
seemingly with liquid passing through
them as if these were some form of
plumbing system k requested to cut the
pipes open using the blowtorch but
control denied and instructed the groups
to follow them instead they did so for
around 300 meters only to find the pipes
continued through a wall that blocked
the team's path under orders to do so
kay ignited the acetylene torch and
began attempting to cut through the
metal surface that stood like a dead end
in their way it was at that point that
jade reported hearing something behind
them although a sweep of her camera
showed the corridor was empty or at the
very least it appeared to be empty
having made a few cuts into the metal
wall kay then allowed leo to use his pry
bar to try and lever a section of it
open to allow the group a way to climb
through the moment he did a loud roar
was heard coming from behind the wall
the terrifying animalistic sound caused
jade to scream backing away in fear only
for something on the other side of the
metal to punch at the blowtorched wall
with enough force to bend its rusted
surface outwards the video feed from
jade's camera unit began to sporadically
cut in and out along with the audio but
what did come through were clear sounds
of a struggle violent roaring and
gunfire from kaye's sidearm along with
screaming from all three members of the
expedition team there was something else
inside the cabinet maze some indigenous
lifeform that roamed the long dark metal
corridors that was attacking the latest
three to venture inside only jade made
it back to the entrance of the labyrinth
by following the chalk markers the group
had been leaving on the walls along the
way it is because of how effective this
practice is that we've been encouraging
you to make sure you do the same once
inside as cp-432 by the time this
d-class returned she was in clear state
of complete and utter distress as well
as being severely injured she was
covered in blood not all of it her own
neither jade's fellow d-class leo nor
foundation technical assistant k made it
back the personnel waiting outside the
rusty cabinet had to shut scp-432 after
jade emerged in order to prevent
whatever creature was inside from
escaping when they reopened the doors
after enough time had elapsed the
interior corridors of scp-432 had
reconfigured themselves again meaning
the other two members of expedition 4
were lost as for d-class member d-8321
she was terminated shortly after being
debriefed what was perhaps most curious
about this though was that foundation
personnel found a large tuft of brown
animal hair had been caught in her
equipment harness presumably during the
attack the hair smelled notably
unpleasant but analysis showed that it
belonged to a known family of animal
however there was also a number of
notable irregularities within its dna
now that brings us on to expedition
number five in a return to form only a
single member of d-class we'll call him
mike was sent into scp-432 this time
though naturally during your expedition
there will be a few more of you making
your way through these corridors
possibly the most noticeable difference
between this excursion and all of those
that had previously been conducted was
that now no light was being emitted
within the corroded metal tunnels all
the light bulbs that had once offered at
least a low level of visibility were now
smashed with mike noticing there was a
substantial amount of broken glass
littering the floor perhaps the creature
in there got bored and broke them all or
maybe it wanted the advantage of no one
being able to see it guided by the
instructions control was issuing mike
followed a short corridor about 10
meters along before stopping at the
first of the t junctions that seemed to
regularly occur within the cabinet maze
making a left as control told him to
mike kept his torch on pointing ahead of
him to alleviate some of the dark
following and marking each turn that
control instructed that he take much
like all the previous expeditions mike
reported hearing strange noises coming
from within the labyrinth he described
the sound of machinery emanating from
some distant part of the maze as well as
feeling
cold all the bulbs were still broken and
not one that he came into contact with
provided any light taking a break to
drink some water and recharge his energy
with a ration bar mike had reached
almost two and a half thousand meters
into scp-432
making it deeper into the cabinet maze
than anyone previously had well a member
of personnel anyway the reason we say
this is because mike soon discovered
signs that someone else might have been
hiding within the labyrinth he noticed a
few old crumpled tin cans and a bent
fork that had been used to eat their
contents whoever else was that deep
inside of scp-432
would likely still not be alive
especially with the creature lurking in
the corridors although if they were
perhaps it was them who broke all the
lights to keep themselves hidden soon
after mike overheard the sound of a man
sobbing coming from somewhere close by
although control struggled to hear the
same they instructed mike to follow the
noise of the crying and locate the
person responsible chasing through the
dark towards whoever it was mike could
hardly see a thing even with his torch
as a light source hello can you hear me
i'm coming he cried trying to get the
attention of the weeping man instantly a
foundation control technician in his
earpiece told mike not to raise his
voice reapproaching the d-class and
warning that he could draw attention to
himself when mike retorted by asking
what else was down in the corridors of
scp-432
no further answer was provided he paused
at the next junction where the tunnels
intersected hearing a long drawn-out
moaning sound possibly a scream a human
scream the crying stopped immediately
after mike asked control if they had
picked up the sound stating that it
seemed to have come from somewhere
nearby once again control urged him to
continue further into the labyrinth
although now mike was trying to move as
slowly and stealthily as he possibly
could turning a right about 20 meters
further down mike's camera feed showed
that he had reached yet another dead end
the maze blocked his way forward leaning
his ear close to the metal mike listened
for any further signs of life only to
recoil at what he heard beyond the
blocked corridor crunching the noise of
bones being broken and something someone
being eaten by the life form that
resides within
scp-432
control urged mike to get out of there
and he complied although not without
checking over his shoulder the whole
walk back at present we still don't have
an accurate description of the creature
some theories state that it might be
imprisoned inside scp-432
others suggest that it guards the
labyrinth within and protects it from
trespassers and interlopers as for how
other human beings or their remains at
least have been uncovered within the
cabinet maze while a number of homeless
people have been reported missing from
the industrial complex where scp-432 was
first uncovered presumably some of them
used that area for shelter and some
ended up inside the cabinet of course
our current objective is to learn more
about the creature this is where you all
come in so now that we've covered the
previous expeditions into scp-432
if there are no further questions we'd
like you all to walk right this way what
are you waiting for step inside the
cabinet of course we'll let you back out
afterwards now go and check out
scp-3333 tower and
scp-5140 frozen bodies on everest are
alive for more anomalous areas you
really shouldn't try to explore yourself
don't believe us maybe you'll think
twice about taking a trip after you hear
what's waiting for you